I think we're pretty screwed I can
definitely tell you that I have to run
to her can I use profanity
money is here today I'm going tomorrow
the stress is there my bank account
empties in like a few months you know I
get a lot of my food food I'm surviving
your income potential as a bachelor of
fine art is not particularly high I only
have five thousand dollars in debt
luckily a lot probably over a hundred
grand Elias my parents are supporting me
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars I
will be paying off my student loan debt
until I'm about sixty years old
and I feel like hard work goes a long
way yes I think if I work really hard I
will be comfortable I kind of have my
fingers crossed got like this awesome
job and just like breeze through all my
loans
you have the ability I think we just
have to be more creative about how we do
it there's no one path everyone's trying
their own thing together foot in the
door I'm a model active how do I look
yeah it's just good I dance all day
every day we think about things we
change things we change careers I worked
for a couple large corporations doing IT
and then put my jobs to follow my
passion which is competitive pole dance
and circus artists trying to get artwork
out there and my music actually we make
it harder for ourselves so we do more
interesting life
I want to be a writer master of my love
and passion so I don't really see myself
ever retiring I nobody ever won through
his hire I'm just the kind of person
who's way too busy to retire I like to
work I wouldn't mind working until I
keel over at my desk if I make it big or
I make a medium big it won't matter
because I really love this year
you